c'est un garçon il est il est bon il est
il vit avec ses parents et sa sœur et
tout ça et tous les soirs quand il va se
coucher il passe devant la chambre de sa
sœur et sa sœur elle est là elle fait je
veux je veux un homme je veux un
homme
et un jour les parents ils parlent en
weekend et les enfants ils restent à la
maison et il y a le copain de la fille
qui vient à la maison et quand il va se
coucher il voit sa sœur avec le garçon
en train de faire l'amour et ils sont là
ils foncent dans sa chambre il s'allonge
il fait je veux un vélo
dans un autre style elle est on va dire
plus poétique c'est de type sur bourrés
et le premier ils sont au pied d'un
lampadaire il fait quoi
je te dis que ça ça c'est imaginaire tu
as besoin
ça c'est la lune alors c'est pas
possible
[Rires]
c'est le soleil si tu continues
pas de problème
c'est la Lune ou le soleil ça après toi
je suis pas je suis pas du quartier
[Applaudissements]
j'en ai une que j'adore j'adore cette
histoire j'adore c'est un tibi viens
chez lui avec trois femmes
et ça ça fait parce que je vais épouser
l'une des trois je voudrais que tu
devines laquelle c'est un millième un
millième de seconde elle fait celle du
milieu il fait comment ça deviner si
vite en fait c'est la seule que j'aime
pas
la sacrée
[Applaudissements]
qui se passe dans un zoom
c'est un couple ils arrivent ils sont
dans le zoo et tout d'un coup il passe
devant la cage de l'orang-outan au dos
argenté et alors Laurentin il voit la
femme il fait
le mari fait tu as vu tu as regardé tu
as regardé mais non
c'est un peu elle avance près de la
grille
[Rires]
ouvre un peu ton chemisier mais ça va
pas ou quoi il y a personne n'ouvre un
peu ton jeu elle ouvre un peu le
chemisier
c'est extraordinaire je te jure c'est
formidable regarde non mais ouvre
complètement
mais non tu es fou il y a du monde non
il y a personne ouvre les chemisier elle
ouvre le chemisier
oh [__] j'ai eu bon on s'en foutage
[Rires]
[Musique]
il prend sa femme il a généré
[Applaudissements]
dans une bibliothèque et il fait bonjour
on est dans une bibliothèque ah pardon
alors je voudrais
[Applaudissements]
il marche il marche le long de la place
il y a une bouteille qui arrive rejetée
par la mer il prend la bouteille le
bouteille un génie qui sort il fait tu
m'as sauvé
[Rires]
qu'est-ce que tu veux de moi veut et il
sort une carte de France il dit tu vois
ça c'est la France c'est mon pays ce que
j'aimerais c'est que la France ce soit
le monde entier que tout le monde entier
sur la France pour certains c'est un
cauchemar mais pour lui c'est
montre-moi la carte
génie génial je suis un génie de
deuxième catégorie tient pas une autre
elle est très misogyne cette histoire et
tu as pas une autre vœu il fait oui il y
a pas de problème il sort la photo de sa
femme il fait regarde tu vois ce que
j'aimerais ça c'est ma femme ce que
j'aime c'est qu'elle soit comme si comme
ça comme ça comme ça et qu'elle arrête
de m'énerver dis donc moi la photo et
regarde la photo il fait redonne-moi la
carte
alors Michel tu veux que tu étais avec
Jean-Marie Bigard
je m'en souviens on faisait pipi au bord
du lac et moi j'ai dit le fond de l'air
est frais et Jean-Marie m'a fait le fond
de l'eau aussi
c'est sur un
tournage c'est dans un film et il y a
met en scène et ils font sauter un fort
un château fort ils ont mis les charges
et tout partout et il a
50 caméras
il fait attention
bah on va tourner
annonce première caméra deuxième attaque
51 attention
ça va sauter attention
c'est magnifique coupé c'est magnifique
alors moi caméra j'ai pas entendu
mais quand j'ai entendu j'ai actionné la
caméra ça a tourné mais il avait déjà
sauté
alors nous on a un problème
d'enchaînement
sur la deuxième caméra c'est ça la
pellicule
c'est pas grave alors nous on a une
panne de batterie
et toutes les caméras comme ça il arrive
à la 50e il est en larmes
s'il vous plaît dis-moi quelque chose tu
es la dernière caméra bah dis-moi
quelque chose c'est quand vous voulez
[Applaudissements]
c'est un couple
ils sont à l'hôpital et la femme est
dans le lit elle a elle a des
très mal elle est très très mal et son
mari là il adore et tout ça elle dit mon
amour vient
il faut que je te demande quelque chose
il fait tout ce que tu veux ma chérie
tout ce que tu veux
il s'approche comme ça
une dernière fois c'est ça pas ou quoi
on est à l'hôpital tu étais avec des
pères c'était malin tout ça ça va pas
fais-moi l'amour fais-moi l'amour une
dernière fois je t'en supplie fais-moi
l'amour
il va il prend la chaise il bloque la
porte
on y va
il va dans le lit il commence à lui
faire l'amour et à ce moment ils font
l'amour et elle elle les joues qui
deviennent rose elle commence à avoir du
plaisir elle est heureuse ça se passe
très très bien c'est formidable et tout
ça
quand ils ont fini elle est là elle
arrache les pères elle se lève du lit
elle fait juste en pleine forme on
rentre à la maison et l'autre il reste
sur le lit il pleure il fait pourquoi tu
pleures quand je pense que j'aurais pu
sauver ma mère
il y en a une que j'aime beaucoup c'est
un type qui rentre dans une
une église ou une synagogue on va dire
une synagogue parce que c'est plus
proche de moi et
il voit un type dans la synagogue et il
lui dit vous êtes le schémach le
shemmèche dans une saguette c'est comme
le Budo dans une église d'accord il fait
vous êtes le schéma je fais moi le
chemin un peu d'eau Nicolas
il fait moi le Budo tu prends pour un
con quoi tu veux que je te tape sur
l'épaule
c'est chaud au dessus du beurre
fait tu sais quoi tu vois tu regardes
bien je vais te mettre une claque je
vais démonter la tête ok je suis au
dessus du rabat pardon pardon c'est le
rabbin de tout toute la ville
mais tu sais quoi je te parle plus à toi
tu m'intéresses pas sors d'ici sort
d'ici je vais te tuer il sert pardon je
suis au dessus de tout le rabbin de
toute la ville quoi vous êtes le rabbin
de tout le pays il fait j'en peux plus
de toi 20 ans je suis au-dessus du
Ramadan de tout le pays à la fin tu fais
quoi tu es Dieu il fait j'ai tué j'ai
frappé je vais te tuer je vais te tuer
je suis au-dessus de Dieu mais monsieur
au-dessus de Dieu il y a rien voilà ce
que je suis
il y a un restaurateur il a un cheval le
cheval il pleure toute la journée il
pleure toute la journée il en peut plus
le restaurateur il met une pancarte fait
celui qui a fait qui arrive à faire rire
mon cheval je lui plais bouffer pendant
un an
et un mec qui arrive plein de mec qui
essaye évidemment personne n'a rien en
dépression il pleure toute la journée et
un petit carré prend le cheval il
s'enferme dans la pièce à côté et il
ressort bout de 5 le cheval il meurt de
rire il est comme ça il se tape les
sabots comme ça
il rigole il rigole il meurt derrière et
il meurt de toute la journée chaque fois
que le petit robot bouffer parce qu'il a
gagné il regarde il meurt de rien il le
fait comme ça il rigole
dans la mare et il dit il dit au petit
coup de si tu arrives à le refaire
pleurer je préfère comment il était
avant frérot prends le cheval il
s'enferme dans une pièce avec lui il
ressort le cheval il est là avant l'arme
il pleure il pleure toute la journée il
pleut le restaurateur il appelle le
petit fait dis-moi comment tu as fait
pour le faire je lui ai dit que j'avais
un sexe plus gros que le sien
il est mort de rire et pour le faire
pleurer tu as fait comment il fait j'ai
montré
c'est l'histoire de Friedrich et Greta
ça commence
et dès sa naissance Hans n'aba prononcé
un mot ni un son c'est le silence
d'audace
et n'auriez pas trop sinon je vais la
rallonger pendant 2 jours
[Rires]
a examine l'enfant il dit cet enfant est
formidable il n'a aucun défauts
et Hans maintenant à deux ans il n'a
toujours pas beau
rien ni aucun son
alors Friedrich et Greta vont voir le
docteur
Gruber examine l'enfant
trois ans je peux elle finit quand il a
13 ans
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quand on est en voiture sur la route je
fais six mois par mois et mon équipe qui
vient
il a toujours pas bronzé
ils vont avoir le docteur
j'en ai marre c'est d'enfant qui est
formidable il n'a aucun de vous
trois ans et demi
qui est en dépression
[Musique]
j'en peux plus
je vous dis
c'est une merveille des merveilles
et finalement c'est mercredi
le jour de la soupe de topinamour
Friedrich amène l'assiette
la soupe de tomber Namour il porte la
cuillère à zabouche
vous êtes tous passionné parce que là ça
a changé vous dit on se rapproche de la
fin
c'est vrai
dans la bouche et il pense accueillir il
fait ça manque des ailes
[Rires]
maintenant ça fait des années qu'on a
comme ça qu'est-ce qui se passe il est
regardé il fait
juste
c'est l'histoire d'une comment dire ça
se passe dans une au départ dans une
boîte de nuit il y a un garçon un gros
dragueur et il a une croise une fille
très jolie et tout ça et ils partent
ensemble et font l'amour toute la nuit
vers 3h du matin il est épuisé et il
sort de la chambre et la femme elle est
sur le lieu fait je veux de l'amour je
veux de l'amour je veux de l'amour je
veux de l'amour
il est vexé mais vexé comme les hommes
peuvent être vexé dans ce genre de
situation
et il appelle des copains qui sont des
balaises et ils s'enferme avec la femme
il reste deux jours au bout de deux
jours elle va te plaire aux deux bouts
je les ressortent ils sont comme ça la
femme elle est sur les fiches je veux de
la montre
il appelle les champions du monde
il reste une semaine avec elle il
ressort comme ça elle est sur les fesses
qui va au zoo de tout à l'heure il va
voir le gorille au doigté et il explique
que chaque fait l'amour il fait un coup
de craie sur le mur
longtemps une semaine disons 15 jours au
bout de 15 jours la femme vous serez
comme ça
je veux de la créer
en Belgique
on est devenu belge et je suis dans le
bar et avec lui et je fais c'est dingue
ça c'est incroyable ça on a pris
l'accent
c'est dingue c'est incroyable ça je ne
reviens pas qu'est-ce qui se passe
je vais te le dire
le miroir comme ça il regarde je regarde
comme c'est incroyable ça heureusement
la question
incroyable c'est que le type là je le
connais je suis sûr que je ne connais
alors pour moi montre voilà prends le
miroir il fait bien sûr que tu le
connais c'est moi
ça se passe
un peu avant la guerre et la deuxième
guerre mondiale et c'est ça se passe
dans un petit village où il y a que des
Juifs qui s'appellent un stettle
et ils apprennent que les nazis vont
arriver
pour les arrêter
alors ils ont une grosse réunion et ils
disent qu'est-ce qu'on va faire pour pas
qu'il nous attrape
rien qui dit moi je pense que ça serait
bien qu'on aille dans la campagne
sinon dans la campagne ils vont chercher
ils vont nous trouver c'est sûr il fait
bon dans la montagne dans la montagne
aussi ils vont voir que le village est
venime vous cherchez dans la montagne et
de trouver c'est sûr il y en a un qui
dit moi j'ai une idée géniale on va se
mettre dans le puits
on se met tous ils nous cherchons jamais
dans le puits il y en a un qui dit mais
c'est pas possible parce que si on est
dans le puits il y aura plus d'écho
parce que le puit il sera plein de nous
et l'autre il fait c'est pas grave on va
faire les cons nous-même
[Rires]
il se cache dans le puits arrivent les
Allemands et le colonel allemand qui
fait il faut trouver les Juifs
il faut lui trouver vite ils vont dans
le village et son effet son pas dans
le vide à ce moment-là le colonel il
s'appuie sur la margelle du puits fais
comment ils sont pas dans le village
alors les autres il faut le village le
village
ou alors peut-être ils sont dans la
montagne
[Rires]
tous dans le pays font
c'est un moineau il est dans la forêt
je te veux je te veux un coup de foudre
je te veux je te veux je te veux je veux
te [__] je veux te [__] je vais te
[__] c'est plus drôle quand on emploie
ce terme
regarde toi regarde-moi tout nous sépare
c'est impossible je m'en fous je m'en
fous ça coup de fou je veux te [__] je
vais te [__]
au bout d'un moment c'est bon bah vas-y
au moineau
chimpanzé qui est là allongé sur une
branche entrain de manger une noix de
coco et il fait je rêve c'est dingue qui
est en train de se passer je vois un
moineau qui nique un éléphant j'ai
jamais vu ça
rit tellement le chimpanzé que il lâche
la noix de coco elle tombe sur la tête
de l'éléphant et
le mono ici
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]